hi in this video we are going to look at
how enzymes work and this is the
introductory video of my enzymology
playlist
we very often say enzyme reacts with
substrate and make the products and
substrate is kind of complementary
towards the enzymes active site so in
this video we are going to look at
what is exactly happening while enzyme
and substrates are interacting we are
going to look at the kinetic data we are
going to look at the thermodynamic and
structural
aspect of this interaction so stay tuned
till the end of the video now here is
a graph which would help us to
understand how enzyme and substrate work
so in the x axis of the graph you have
the reaction progression
so it's kind of like a time and in the y
axis you have free energy change
now without any enzyme if you
add some substrate it would be
eventually become a product but it would
take a lot of time
so that graph kind of looks like this
where you have the energy of the
reactants as initial part
and then eventually it would get
converted into the product
now the difference between
the energy of the reactant and the
transition state is actually the
activation
energy so activation energy without the
enzyme
kind of look like this but if you have
an enzyme
which can catalyze this reaction then
the graph kind of look like this
as you can quite notice that the
activation
energy has been reduced to start the
reaction with the enzyme right now
this reduction in the activation energy
is the key
aspect of enzyme substrate
reaction because enzyme reduce the
active
activation energy so what is activation
energy actually the difference between
the energy levels of the ground state
and the transition state can be defined
as activation energy
now the enzyme and enzyme substrate
interaction actually decrease the
activation
energy of the react enzyme substrate
reaction
and moreover enzyme change the reaction
rate but enzyme does not change the
equilibria
this is one of the most important aspect
about how enzyme
enzymatic reactions work
now let's try to understand things in
bit more details and try to understand
how
enzyme specificity is bring about
so here is an enzyme which is binding to
this particular substrate
but this particular enzyme is not going
to bind with another substrate like this
given here one reason is
there is a mismatch or this particular
substate
is not fitting into the enzymes active
site
and in order to understand all of these
aspects we need to
look at the structural aspect of these
enzyme substrate interaction
and with the development of x-ray
crystallographic technique
structural biology has really flourished
and looking at the enzyme substrate
bound structure
or the enzyme structure individually in
an unbound situation
and crystallizing both of these
conformations and followed by doing a
extra crystallographic technique
scientists have found out how exactly
enzyme substrate works
and they figured out that there are
several principles which are
associated with the catalytic power and
the specificity of the enzyme so we are
going to look at that
in a moment so there are two key
principles first of all
there is something called binding energy
which augments the enzyme substrate
interaction
and there is something called
stereospecificity
of an enzyme which is occurring due to
the 3d conformation of the
enzymes active site or let's say the way
enzymes active site is interacting with
the substrate
now let's talk about binding energy
first
so the energy that is derived from the
enzyme substrate interaction
maybe it's a weak interaction that is
known as the binding energy
binding energy is the major source of
energy that is used by the enzyme to
lower the activation
energy so the key aspect of the enzyme
substrate reaction is enzyme reduce the
activation energy for this reaction
right
and thereby augment the rate and
this is provided by the binding energy
so what exactly is the binding energy
let's say this substrate is bound with
an
enzyme and in the active site there are
several interactions
non-covalent or equivalent interactions
are forming in the active site for
example a hydrogen
bond is formed between uh
two particular residues between these
two
substrate and enzyme that bond formation
energy
is actually contributing towards binding
energy now there is not only one
interaction there could be multiple
different small small interactions some
are hydrogen bonds some are maybe
hydrophobic interactions some are maybe
van der waals interaction
so all summation of all these bond
formation
energies would contribute to the
binding energy and that has
very good important implications right
now that actually gives enzyme the
catalytic power
and also these weak interactions are
optimized
in the reactions transition state
and it has to be remembered that enzymes
conformation the active site
conformation is exactly complementary to
the substrate
not in the ground state but in the
transition state in order to understand
that let us try to
visualize this process so this is the
enzyme
now its active site is not totally
complementary to the substrate's
stereo specificity so the substrate
first
bind a site away to the
active site and there are multiple
small interactions happening between the
enzyme and substrate
but while the enzyme substrate reaction
is going through a transition state
in that situation the sub the
conformation of the
active site is also changed actually it
is induced by the initial weak
interactions between the enzyme and
substrate
and that change the conformation of the
active site such that the
substrate fits nicely in the
active site of the enzyme and this is
the importance of the binding energy so
what we learned from this
is there is loose binding of enzyme and
substrate in the ground state
but the form binding occurs in the
transition state only
which augments this process and lowers
the activation energy in fact
the binding energy is providing the
energy
to to lower the activation energy and
thereby
ultimately the reaction can go on and
products are formed
and we also learned that the optimal
interaction between substrate and enzyme
is only occurring in the transition
state not in the ground state
now that leads us to
understand what are the physical factors
or thermodynamic constraints in case of
a
reaction to occur now there are
many factors which can constrain a
reaction to occur
and i'm going to point out few of them
for example the entropy
so the entropy overall is a estimation
of the disorderness
in kind in case of any reaction it also
determines how is the
how much is the freedom of motion of two
molecules in a solution
right and entropy entropy has to be
reduced and we are going to talk about
it in a moment
other than that the solvation shell
which is present
around the substrate and the enzyme
might prevent
them to interact with each other
optimally and then
for ultimately the need of proper
alignment of the catalytic
sites like that means the enzymes active
site and the
substrate is very important because this
three dimensional arrangement
is what allows the enzyme substrate
reaction to proceed further
so let's try to understand three points
one by one
let's say there are few enzymes and
substrate present in this particular
solution all the enzymes are marked in
red and the substrate are marked in blue
now see they are very dynamic and they
are displaying brownian motion
now if they are not settling down
or they are not settling down or their
entropy is reduced
then what is happening then the
the probability or the likelihood that
they are going to interact with each
other or they are going to collide with
each other is
low so first and foremost thing that the
enzyme does is to reduce the entropy
and the entropy reduction is actually
taking place by formation of these small
small interactions
that is actually the binding energy is
allowing the enzyme
to reduce the entropy of the enzyme
substrate interaction
now along with that we have to
understand that these
enzymes and the substrates both are
actually soluble in a solution
right so they have lot of hydration
shell around it so lot of water
molecules are actually
covering up the surfaces of the enzyme
and substrate
these covering up of the surface might
be
a little problem because if the surfaces
are not open the
functional groups are not open then then
how the small interactions would be
happening
so these desolvation is important
and the solvation problem is overcome
by the energy of binding energy so the
binding energy provides
sufficient amount of energy which can
cause desolvation and
lastly the enzyme and the substrate need
to be oriented
properly in a three-dimensional space
such that the optimal
interaction between the enzymes active
site and the substrate can
take place all these three factors are
governing the rate of the enzyme
substrate reactions
and that is how actually binding energy
augments the reaction rate by lowering
activation energy
so we pretty much understand how enzyme
and substrate work
not really because this is the first and
foremost and the easiest
explanation towards the enzyme substrate
interaction but there are more to it
because there are many other molecules
apart from the substrate which can bind
to the enzymes such as allosteric
regulators
these allosteric regulators can also
change the
active site conformation and augment
substrate binding
or prevent substrate binding so these
kind of fine regulations of enzymatic
functions are also there
now in this video i'm not going to talk
about allosteric regulation i have a
different video for allosteric
regulation so don't forget to check my
enzymology playlist where i have pretty
much covered
a lot of topics regarding enzymology and
enzyme kinetics
so don't forget to check out this if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up and don't forget to like share and
subscribe
thank you